Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor GREENE blurted
out classified information at a public hearing.
Doubled down and said, I don't care.
The public deserves to know.
This is someone who is on the Homeland Security
Committee and she doesn't believe in the importance
of confidentiality.
Let's take a look at a video clip in which
you will see Marge divulging classified information
at a hearing about the US-Mexico border.
And you will see that when she is told this
is not really the appropriate place to be
talking about that, she says, I don't give
a damn my words, not hers.
She uses other language.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: Tea Parties.
Are you aware that there was an explosive
device found by Border Patrol agents on January
17th in an area called No Man's Land?
And there's surveillance of who put it there.
And guess what?
It wasn't Americans.
It was cartels.
Are you aware of that?
Thank you, Congresswoman, and good to see
you again.
I will tell you that some of this information
that I receive, I receive in a confidential
script.
So I'm going to be a little hesitant of briefing
what I know and what I don't know with respect
to some of those an event like that.
I understand tea parties, but I'm not going
to be confidential because I think people
deserve to know.
Our Border Patrol agents should not be in
those type of border Patrol conditions where
they are at risk of being blown to pieces
by the cartels, who, by the way, are criminals.
Mm hmm.
Speaker 1: She's not going to be confidential.
She has just decided.
Now we'll get to whether that's something
she's allowed to do as a member of Congress,
seemingly doubling down on this.
She then went to Tweeter and posted, quote,
If the device in question was just filled
with sand, then why would Chief Ortiz tell
me during his testimony that he was briefed
about it in a skiff and couldn't comment on
classified information, then turn around afterwards
and tweet a picture of it, claiming it was
filled with sand with thousands of people
and huge amounts of drugs flooding across
the border every day.
They don't brief the chief of Border Patrol
in a skiff about a ball of sand.
They only brief us about dangerous things
in classified briefings.
So she seems to be acknowledging that it is
up to her to decide what gets to stay classified
and what doesn't.
Now, a reasonable question when we say how,
how does government function?
And of course, if you want to know how government
functions, you don't go to Marjorie Taylor.
GREENE She doesn't know.
Do members of Congress have the you could
call it the ability, the right?
Are they are they allowed whatever term you
want to use?
Can she decide unilaterally what gets to remain
confidential and what should be made public
in this way?
And the answer is, of course, as I'm sure
many of you suspect, with better instincts
than Marjorie Taylor.
GREENE the answer is no.
Members of Congress do not have the ability
or the authority to declassify classified
information on their own during public hearings.
It is important for responsible and sensible
members of Congress to understand they may
be able to discuss certain aspects of classified
or confidential information they have seen,
but they should be careful not to disclose
anything that is still confidential or classified.
They can discuss the general nature of classified
information but should not reveal specific
details.
And Marjorie Taylor GREENE did everything
in this moment that she is not authorized
to do.
If a member of the House of Representatives
wants to declassify information because they
believe it is a public interest or believe
it should be discussed in a public setting,
the way Marge seems to believe, they have
a protocol and a series of procedures within
the executive branch.
You submit a request to the agency that originally
classified the information or you petition
the president for declassification.
They claim to be about law and order.
And then Marjorie Taylor GREENE says, Me,
I've decided I'm not going to be confidential
about this.
And she does it brazenly.
And the saddest part about all of this is
that her followers will defend anything she
does in a vacuum.
She and her followers are about law and order,
and they will say we're about law and order.
That's why we're against Antifa, as they now
call it.
That's why we're against Hunter Biden.
You know, we've got to investigate Hunter
Biden because of law and order, and they're
all about law and order until all of a sudden
law and order would say she's not supposed
to be talking about this.
And it's certainly not within her authority
to disclose certain things during a public
hearing.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
She's doing the people's work because she's
being transparent and she's informing us.
Oh, well, what about her lack of transparency
in this other area when it came to campaign
finance?
No, that's also okay there for her not to
be transparent because the campaign finance
rules are being weaponized against.
They will always have some way to get around
the principles that they claim to abide by
law and order, fiscal conservatism, personal
responsibility, low regulation until it conflict.
Well, what about forcing Twitter to publish
anti-vax stuff you want to now get involved
in, say, Twitter, you must publish that.
That's against your principle of low regulation.
Well, no, that's different because big tech
free speech censoring, but a little level
of that.
Oh, okay.
Every time you think you've got them because
they violated one of their own stated principles,
they just excuse their way out of it.
This is the way that they operate.
And that's how Marjorie Taylor GREENE followers
are reacting to her, just blurting out classified
information and then saying, Damn right I
did, because the people deserve to know.
Few are listening today.
And you'd like to see this clip of Marjorie
Taylor GREENE.
I don't know why you would torture yourself
like that, but if you did want to, we'll have
the clip on our YouTube channel, YouTube.com
slash The David Pakman Show.
And we will also have it on the Spanish YouTube
channel at David Pakman dot com slash Spanish.
The David Pakman Show is a viewer and the
listener supported program.
The show we do every day.
The podcast, the YouTube channel, the Spanish
dubbing, the TV show, the radio show, the
tech talks, all of this stuff.
We have a team and the primary funding source
for all of that is direct member subscriptions.
I love that we make all of this stuff available
for free.
I also love, as we will talk about with David
Sirota in a little bit.
When we talk about how we fund what we do,
we are mostly funded directly by the audience.
The upside of this is there's no one company
or person that can say we're shutting off
the faucet unless you do X, Y, Z, because
we spread out our support through our audience.
No one entity can shut us down effectively.
The counterpoint to this is that sometimes
people will email me and they'll say, David,
I really didn't like what you said about whatever.
I'm canceling my membership.
Yes, we do have to deal with that, but we're
in a position not to have to change what we
do because we've upset anybody in particular
leads to some awkward emails, I can tell you.
But I believe that it is the best way to fund
the work that we do.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.
We've got a long list of member benefits that
you can read about there and you can use the
coupon code.
24 starts now to save yourself A It's a substantial
discount, let me put it that way.
I don't want you know, Tish James coming after
me, making me the next target of a grand jury.
So I won't tell you how large the discount
is, but it's large when you use the code.
24 starts now.